bonjour spy wen
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct ce matin sur rtl france
françois pupponi va nous rejoindre dans
quelques instants par téléphone ça tombe
bien ça grogne vous êtes vous êtes
adhérent les républicains et vous avez
créé un comité de soutien pour eric
zemmour expliquez nous pourquoi
l'on ressentait le besoin de pouvoir
coupler donc la génération z déjà bien
en présentant des territoires et les
amis d'eric zemmour donc créé un
comité de soutien pourra aussi servir à
l'avenir quand il y aura donc un parti
politique officiellement déclaré et ça
sert aussi directement à mobiliser et
organiser déjà l'ensemble est troublée
dante et d'autre l'équipe possible
qu'ils démarchent etc les maires
concernés qui pourrait donner leurs
parrainages voilà donc vous êtes l armée
vous soutenez avec zemmour car non
ça n'a pas été très bien accueilli
partout
d'autres l'ont bien compris
mais ça reste quelque chose d'assez tu
assez tendue au sein des républicains
est ce que vous avez subi des pressions
et re j'imagine que vous allez donner
votre parrainage à eric zemmour est ce
que vous avez suivi des dépressions
depuis votre prise de position
non je ne parlerai pas de pression s'ils
sont des personnes qui sont en désaccord
que des fois je n'ai pas pu prévenir à
temps parce qu'il ya un article qui a
paru un nouvelle république donc non
j'ai pas eu de pression particulière les
deux travaillent les personnes avec qui
je travaillais parmi les républicains
sont mes sens pas comme ça mais pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi justement de délaisser
les républicains
les républicains aujourd'hui ils ne
représentent plus la droite française
mais plutôt aimé droite centriste s'est
malheureusement
dû à des accords ils ont avec d'autres
partis politiques plutôt des centres et
ça ne me représente plus ce pourquoi les
personnes à des rires le capitaine du
peuple tous ceux qui étaient pires qui
vous avez trouvé le droit de retenir se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec une autre ils
ont replié les clubs français avec
d'autres candidats repartent avec les
mots les autres candidats huit ne sont
pas le démon qui ont quitté les
républicains vous parlez de valérie
pécresse et de xavier bertrand donc
finalement il n'ya plus d'hommes forts
qui incarne de ce party les républicains
c'est ce que vous déclarez c'est ce que
vous trouvez en 0
c'est ce que je trouve en amérique
zemmour et j'avoue que hutu l'élu moi
j'étais prêt à suivre laurent coq et
qu'à mon sens c'est quelqu'un de fort
respectable et digne mais qui s'est
retiré pour justement éviter de briser
et de séparer cette famille républicaine
et pour ça je le respecte fortement mais
le problème c'est que aujourd'hui on
voit là nous retrouvons avec eux
principalement quand même xavier
bertrand qui à mon sens ne représente
pas les républicains comme il faudrait
du tout pourquoi du congrès finalement
c'est pas la bonne solution pour
déterminer le candidat ait l'air
je ne sais pas si c'est si c'est le bon
choix à faire mais le problème c'est
qu'avec un problème dijon ce qui
m'étonne c'est qu'on entend dire xavier
bertrand qui ne participeraient pas une
primaire et quelques jours plus tard on
entend que finalement les oublie cette
idée de primaires pour faire un congrès
donc à mon avis c'était la seule
solution envisageable pour trouver un
accord entre les autres candidatures et
xavier bertrand gros elle à votre
connaissance est ce que eric zemmour awa
les capacités de recueillir les 500
signatures nécessaires pour se présenter
à l'élection présidentielle
oui je ne dirai pas où ça en est mais
c'est bien parti je ne m'inquiète pas
spécialement pour les signatures parce
que beaucoup de maires partage mon avis
beaucoup d'autres qui ne paraît pas
spécialement dans le passé ou qui sont
nouvellement élus
sont prêts à parrainer aujourd'hui parce
qu'ils sont là par intérêt pour la
france qui sont des personnes qui sont
confrontées ou non à certaines
problématiques
dont parle à eghezée moore dans ses
discours mais qu'ils comprennent que
ailleurs en dehors de leur commune ou en
dehors de leur département d'autres
personnes sont confrontées à ce jour
dans des cas pareils nous sommes
actuellement avec françois pupponi qui a
pu nous rejoindre par téléphone bonjour
françois pupponi
merci beaucoup de nous rejoindre
dans ce débat je ne sais pas si vous
avez pu entendre la dernière les
derniers mots de de style gros l on
parlait de et moore qui était en bonne
passe en tout cas d'avoir les 500
signatures pour pour la présidentielle
je vais vous demander tout d'abord votre
votre réaction évidemment à ce sondage
qui n'est qu'un sondage on s'en méfie
bien sûr il est trop tôt pour présager
du reste mais en tout cas ça te dit
quelque chose le fait que eric zemmour
soit au second tour selon ce sondage ont
écouté le sondage n'est que la
confirmation d'une dynamique que nous
constatons depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines sondage après sondage c'est
qu'effectivement entre eric des mots et
marine le pen marine le pen les courbes
se croisent comme on vit un et donc
effectivement il ya une dynamique au
cours des rites et pour personne de
colombier se trouve à ce que fait que le
confirmer est ce qu'il y aurait une
nostalgie politique d'aidé française
maïwenn selon vous avec la révélation de
ce sondage zemmour qui se dit du rpr
gaulliste je pense que la forte d'eric
zemmour c2c de parler de ce sujet qu'un
certain nombre de français vivent
contrairement à d'autres candidats mais
c'est pas nouveau parce que ces sujets
liés à l'immigration ya la ghettoïsation
liée à la dynamique lui il va plus loin
libre sur ce dakar et plusieurs types
critique systématiquement la place de
l'islam dans votre pays mais ces sujets
là parlent pas français et pour
l'instant c'est un des seuls candidats
en parler l'oncle et certaines personnes
dignes valu au moins ils parlent de
sujets qui nous préoccupent mais s'ils
sont pas les tickets préoccupation
première lorsqu on étudiait un peu les
études là dessus daisy parle de ces
sujets là voilà ici et moi je suis de
ceux qui disent que l'eau les autres
candidats en particulier sur le bon camp
doivent parler au 6 juillet pour faire
des choses qui sont en contradiction
exclu dit eric thébault mais au moins
que le débat ait lieu donc vous
reconnaissons vous reconnaissez son
franc parler et ça a le mérite au moins
de mettre un peu un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière c'est ce que vous n'y êtes
avec évidence évident et il fait un peu
ce que faisait jean marie le pen ya
quelques années ça fait un moment marié
d'appel s'est il parle de sujets qui
préoccupent lui partie des français qui
sont une réalité quotidienne à sa part
heureux que les partis traditionnels ont
parfois du mal à aborder
donc je pense que faut que le débat ait
lieu et doit avoir lieu dans l'intérêt
du pays spain en écoute est justement là
est la réaction de valérie pécresse de
xavier bertrand on en parlait en tout à
l'heure de candidats qui ne font plus
chez les républicains c'est ce que vous
déploriez spyware ecoutons-les et
parlons-en après
ça fait 20 ans que je fais de la
politique et il ya des produits
sondagier et des produits électoraux il
y assure tous les sondeurs et les
journalistes aujourd'hui les français ne
sont pas encore entrés dans la
présidentielle maïwenn c'est ce qu'on
entend beaucoup la montée d'eric zemmour
ce serait le produit finalement des
sondages et v et des médias qu'en pensez
vous
moi je ne pense pas que ce soit la
couverture médiatique à travers ces
sondages qui vise à attaquer ou à
critiquer vous positionner dans
l'amérique zemmour qui le fait monter de
telles sortes il s'agit clairement de
l'ambient du peuple français l'envy
d'une vie meilleure et des changements
aujourd'hui les français veulent
retrouver leur fierté et sont
aujourd'hui prêts à franchir le pas en
soutenant la candidature d'eric zemmour
safran parler aujourd'hui long tour sans
même avoir annoncé sa candidature c'est
quand même extraordinaire il faut avouer
que quelque part on commence à écrire
l'histoire
selon ce ne sont que des sondages pour
l'instant mais est-ce que ce
franc-parler est-ce que ça fera en
parler vous le constatez vous chez vos
administrés par exemple
que ce franc-parler qui plaît bien sûr
oui bien sûr c'est très politique un peu
à l'ancienne j'ai envie de dire où on
allait taper sur les sucres et un peu
tableau et c'est ce qui l'a énormément
c'est ce qui l'a énormément jamais eu
dans cette politique politicienne ils
visent tous été formés à formuler à
changer le sens des mots pour que ça
soit plus facilement acceptable il assez
crus parfois un peu trop aussi dans ses
paroles mais c'est ce qui parle aux
français aujourd'hui françois pupponi et
or eric zemmour a si ce sondage se
confirme évidemment aurait réussi à
allier l'électorat populaire de marine
le pen
l'électorat plutôt bourgeois les
républicains c'est la première fois
qu'un cas qu'un candidat en tout cas
parvient à faire cette jonction qu'en
pensez vous
novethic sûrs que tout aussi le pari que
eric zemmour fait depuis le début
considérant que et leur assemblée
nationale et les républicains ne sont
plus capables de parler de certains
sujets et ils ne sont pas capables de
gagner des élections donc il ya pris
cette troisième voie pour réunir les
droites il entraîne le faire en passant
j'ai entendu les réactions de valérie
pécresse et 2 et le biais bertrand il
critique le fait que les médias posent
des bida parle d'eric zemmour et du le
problème s'il faut parler du fond et
attaquer les bourses qui dit au fond ce
que ne font pas des partis traditionnels
puis moins ils le feront et plus
d'attaquants eric zemmour sur sa
personne et plus elle rendra service
donc moi je suis pour que le débat ait
lieu sur le fond et pour démontrer que y
compris certaines solutions proposées
par exem sûrs d'eux sont pas acceptables
et ne sont pas les solutions aux
problèmes qu'ils dérangent alors
justement vous parlez des des attaques
des uns et des autres on va écouter anne
hidalgo et eric dupond moretti le
ministre de la justice qui qui se sont
exprimés sur eric zemmour et regardez
je suis absolument dégoûté jusqu'à la
nausée de la montée d'un personnage dans
la vie politique française
tout le monde fait comme si c'était
naturel normal que quelqu'un vienne sur
toutes les chaînes expliqué que le
maréchal pétain était l'ami des juifs
pendant la guerre faire du révisionnisme
ça me paraît clair il est raciste
négationniste condamné par la justice
pour incitation à la haine raciale
qu'est ce que vous voulez de plus
inspirant elle est ce que c'est
contreproductif ses insultes envers eric
zemmour
dans les sondages c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure il me semble pas que ce
soit s'est passé pas en sa faveur c'est
sûr et certain ce sont des critiques ils
attaquent directement
juridique sans argumentation finalement
oui c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce sont les
seuls arguments qui reste aux opposants
et où d'autres médias c'est à dire
revenir toujours sur ces débats de
prénom et le genci et j'en suis
l'exemple dans mon prénom ils étaient
tous aux français et s'il ne changera
pas
mais c'est les seuls arguments à mon
avis qui reste aux médias et aux
opposants pour attaquer l'eczéma le
dramatiser exemple c'est le racisme de
dramatiser en disant que les iphone
violence on sait quand etc c'est le
fossé de plus que l'on cherche mais si
les arguments everest et revenir sur les
débats et 1 et 2 du régime de vichy ou
alors des prénoms voilà cesser les a
largement tiré ces termes mon avis parce
que sinon c'est là effectivement quant à
eric zemmour avait dit que le régime de
vichy avait protégé les juifs qui lui
colle à la peau françois pupponi même
même question pour vous est ce que
finalement le fait d'insulter eric
zemmour n'est pas contre-productif
c'est contre-productif et c'est ce
qu'ont fait certains partis
traditionnels depuis des années sur jean
marie le pen on voit le résultat
le rassemblent fois la salle plus la
formation d'al ce soir il faut qu'on
trouve au deuxième tour d'une
présidentielle donc elle la
diabolisation de fonctionne pas ça peut
fonctionner j'allais tenir pour éviter
qu'ils gagnent au 2e tour mais ça ne
fonctionne pas moi je pense que le seul
combat qu'il faut mener contre eric
zemmour c'est un combat sur les idées
pour démontrer que s'il y parle hors jeu
reprend ce que ce que ce qu' il n'a pas
aidé à goa dit sur vichy oui
effectivement
dire que péta a protégé des juifs
quand on connaît l'histoire de notre
pays vis-à-vis des lois antijuives
vis-à-vis de collaboration c'est
condamnable contestable il faut le
critiquer il faut dire qu'il est réglé
pour se trompe donc il faut démontrer
que ces arguments ne sont pas des vrais
arguments qui parfois des contrevérités
grippe alors ça il faut d'abord étudier
et de pas attaquer low speed run vous
verrez jamais risée mot indiquent-ils
protéger les juifs il protéger protéger
des vues il protégeait d'appel ce qu'il
a dit à l'époque mais vraiment pas
parler nature ont pas parlé de ça très
longtemps il a dit qu'il
protège et des francs c'est ce qu'il a
dit ça a été ça a été très mal pris ça a
choqué les gens et aujourd'hui c'est ça
revient en continu voilà c'est quelque
chose qui a été dit c'est son
interprétation dans ces méfaits et ans
qui s'est passé c'est pas ça qui va qui
va offrir les débats présidentiels ça
n'a aucun intérêt c'est quand même eric
zemmour qu'il a dit et je pense qu'il a
eu il a fait plus d'erreurs une grave
erreur le régime de pétain a organisé la
déportation des juifs c'est lui
d'organiser la rafle du vel d'hiv et
la déportation
donc on repassera en particulier parmi
tant d'autres de temps là pour montrer
qu'on peut débattre de ce que te
contredire ce que dirait que des bourses
sans pour autant attaquer la personne
le diaboliser et une erreur et pourtant
et pourtant alors voyons ce qu'en dit
eric zemmour justement sur la
diabolisation
je ne vais pas édulcorer mon discours je
me foute de la diabolisation parce que
la diabolisation c'est vous qui la
fabrique est donc je m'en fous
complètement je vous préviens d'avancé
et moi je tiendrai mon discours quelles
que soient les réflexions des médias et
des bien pensants voilà voilà ce qu'il
répond et eric zemmour spyware ça
fonctionne finalement les une partie en
tout cas des électeurs passe outre ce
genre de déclarations il ose dire je
vais voter eric zemmour contrairement à
avant où on n'osait pas dire je vais
voter pour un pur à l'open par exemple
moi je trouve très bien parce que ça
fait ça fait des décennies en cas d'exil
moore défend les mêmes idées c'est
quelqu'un qui au lieu de se contenir se
répète et c'est ça aussi qui fait la
fidélité aujourd'hui les électeurs ou
tout autre électeur qui habituellement
auraient voté plus tôt à ce moment
nationale où les républicains
là nous aujourd'hui ce que l'on cherche
vraiment à expliquer et à montrer si que
nous ne sommes pas
une nouvelle version de ville centre il
y met il rassemble pas du tout et nous
ne sommes pas non plus un parti qui
comme les républicains veut adapter son
discours et ses idées pour réussir
enveloppez plutôt le centrisme qui
existe aujourd'hui dans la vie politique
française
françois françois pupponi
il nous reste très peu de temps vous
êtes d'accord quand eric zemmour dit
qu'il est de droite
d'inspiration et repère des années 60 et
gaullistes mais bien sûr eric zemmour
est de droite ils l'assument il parle
des sujets qui sont plus pour lui des
sujets tabous il qu ils considèrent que
la droite a eu tort de nepal a débordé
et je pense que dans sa logique il a
raison oui effectivement il redit haut
et le droit d utiliser des droits
de droite avec des propos parfois sont
proches de l'extrême droite quand jean
marie le pen dit il est prêt à voter
pour lui les choses sont claires mais il
lâche hub sans tabou et la chute sans
complexe mois et non qu'il faut dès lors
qu'on est contre la droite et l'extrême
droite l'affronter sur les idées je
pense que l'intérêt de cette élection
présidentielle avec sa présence moi je
le dis et que peut-être que nous aurons
enfin le débat sur la construction des
uns et des autres ce qu'elle apprend
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
débattue ce matin en direct sur arte
france le débat donc qui risque d'être
intéressant on verra cela on va en
reparler merci beaucoup